SHUTDOWN TEN RUSSIAN AIRCRAFT
AND THIS IS ALL LAST NIGHT.
>> HEY THERE, GOOD TO SEE YOU.
WE'LL GET TO THE LATEST ON
UKRAINE IN A MOMENT, BUT FIRST,
♪
>> THANKS FOR NOTHING.
>> DID YOU HEAR?
THE HUNTER BIDEN LAPTOP IS REAL
WELCOME AND THIS JUST IN, SO IS
50 PERCENT OF KAT'S HAIR.
>> LESS THAN THAT.
>> I KNOW, I KNOW, TAKE A BREATH
, IT'S AMAZING AFTER THE
CONTENTIOUS 2020 ELECTION AND
MORE DENIALS THAN CHARLIE SHEEN
AT AN AA MEETING, THE NEW YORK
TIMES ADMITS OKAY COMMIT THAT
LAPTOP FULL OF POLITICALLY STUF
ABOUT JOE AND HUNTER BIDEN IS
MORE LEGIT THAN MC HAMMER AT TH
91 GRAMMYS.
OF COURSE, THIS IS NEARLY TWO
YEARS AFTER AN ELECTION THAT JO
MIGHT HAVE LOST IF ALL THAT INF
HADN'T BEEN.
BY THE MEDIA AT THE BEHEST OF
THEIR BUDDIES AT THE POLITICAL
MACHINE.
NOW A MASSIVE REPORT ON THE
ONGOING PROBE HAS CONFIRMED THA
THE INFAMOUS LAPTOP EXISTS.
IN OTHER NEWS, PUTIN IS
PSYCHOTIC, BIDEN IS OLD AND I
COLLECT WATER FROM USED
WATERBEDS.
IT'S DELICIOUS.
A LOT OF FIBER.
WE KNEW THIS, BUT IF WE BROUGHT
IT UP WE WOULD BE MOCKED AND
BANNED.
THE NEW YORK POST WAS RIGHT ALL
ALONG WHEN IN OCTOBER OF 2020
THEY SAID HUNTER DITCHED HIS
LAPTOP AND A DELAWARE REPAIR
SHOP AFTER THE APRIL 2019 AND I
CONTAINED ENOUGH FILTH TO MAKE
HUB WHICH THEY WERE CHRISTIAN
MINGLE.
MY FAVORITE, HE IS MY DADDY,
UNDER THE GRANTOR AND.
THE DOCUMENTS BETWEEN HUNTER,
HIS FAMILY AND BUSINESS
ASSOCIATES.
IN KNOW THE KIND WHO STILL WEAR
BEEPERS.
IT ALSO SHOWS HOW THE FUTURE
PRESIDENTS AND USED HIS
INVOLVING EVERYONE FROM CHINA T
YES EVEN UKRAINE.
TALK ABOUT COLLUSION.
EXCEPT NO, YOU COULDN'T TALK
ABOUT THIS COLLUSION.
THE ONE WHERE THE BIG GUY,
A.K.A. JOE, A.K.A., THE SCRATCH
AND SNIFFER, STOOD TO MAKE
MILLIONS OFF HUNTER MAKING IT
RAIN.
HUNTER WAS LIKE ONE OF THE
STRIPPERS HE HAS BANGED, HE
WOULD SHOW UP, AND THEN THE
GREENWOOD FLOW.
HE WASN'T JUST A SON HE WAS A
TABLE DANCER FROM THE VIP ROOM
CALLING CLIMBING ALL OVER THE
LAPSE OF FOREIGN.
IT MAKES TELLING YOUR NOSE
NOODLES AT A ART GALLERY SEEM
RESPECTABLE GREAT I WONDER WHAT
JOE HAD TO SAY ABOUT THE LAPTOP
NOW PART.
>> I REMEMBER WHEN COMPUTER USE
TO TAKE UP A WHOLE ROOM, AND NO
THEY'VE GOT THEM SO SMALL, AND
YOU CAN WORK ALL DAY ON YOUR LAP
, AND I'M NOT SURPRISED THAT
HE HAD ONE OF THESE THINGS.
HE ALWAYS HAD THE LATEST
TECHNOLOGY.
I REMEMBER ONE TIME HE HAD A
DEVICE HE COULD FIT RIGHT IN
YOUR POCKET AND I SAID HUNTER
WHAT IS THAT AND HE SAID DAD, I
USE THAT TO SMACK SMOKE CRACK
COCAINE AND I SAID WAY, I DON'T
NEED TO KNOW WHAT YOU'RE DOING
IN YOUR PRIVATE LIFE.
JUST MAKE SURE I GET 10 PERCENT.
>> PERFECT.
BUT HEY, HIS DAD IS RIGHT, AFTE
ALL, EVERYBODY KNOWS SOMEBODY
SOMEWHERE ALONG THE LINE THERE.
>> I BET EVERYBODY KNOWS
SOMEBODY SOMEWHERE ALONG THE
LINE THAT IN A RELATIONSHIP WAS
HAPPENING WAS THAT GUY TAKES A
REVEALING PICTURE OF HIS NAKED
FRIEND OR WHATEVER IN A
COMPROMISING POSITION.
AND THEN, LITERALLY INNOCENT
BLACK MALES OR MORTIFIED AS THA
PERSON.
SEND IT OUT, PUT IT ONLINE.
>> JUST READ IT IN MAGAZINE AT
THE DENTIST OFFICE WHERE DID YO
HEAR ABOUT THIS THING.
YOU WOULD THINK JOE MIGHT SEE
THE HYPOCRISY AND ALL OF THAT,
EVERYBODY KNOWS SOMEBODY WHO'S
BEEN FILMED IN COMPROMISING
POSITIONS.
MAY BE SO, BUT THEY DIDN'T WRITE
, ACT, DIRECT, AND PAY THE
OTHER ACTORS IN BLOW, YES IT'S
YOUR SON AND HE WAS DOING THE
FILMING AND THE ACTING AND ALSO
THE BLOW.
MAYBE HE DOES HAVE A FUTURE IN
HOLLYWOOD.
WHAT AND WHO IS BEING
COMPROMISED HERE, THE, THE DRUG
DEALERS COME AT THE MOTEL SIX IS
?
IT WAS THE BIDEN FAMILY.
NOT EXACTLY A SIMPLE CASE OF
REVENGE.
AND WONDER HOW MANY PEOPLE HAD
TO BE PAID OFF BECAUSE OF THAT
COMPROMISE SITUATION, WHICH IS
WHY THAT LAPTOP HAD TO BE DEAD
AND.
LIKE IT WAS FRIENDS WITH HILLAR
CLINTON.
ITS WHY YOU DON'T KNOW JACK
ABOUT THE OTHERS IN THE TAPES O
THE DRUG DEALERS.
UNLIKE JOE'S PEACE, THE LAPTOP,
IT'S REAL.
IT DOESN'T MATTER NOW DOES IT?
IT KIND OF DOES.
WITH FOOD AND HAVE INVADED
UKRAINE IF TRUMP WAS STILL IN
OFFICE?
EVEN DEMS HAVE ASKED THAT
QUESTION.
BECAUSE EVERYBODY KNOWS YOU NEE
TO DEAL WITH A PSYCHOPATH, PUTI
ISN'T FICTIONAL CHARACTER, BUT
TRUMP IS NOT IN OFFICE, JOE IS
AND HE GOT THERE BECAUSE OF
LIKE-MINDED DEMOCRATS MEDIA
TITANS AND NEVER TRUMPER
REPUBLICANS MADE IT SO BY
BEARING THE LAPTOP LIKE IT WAS
GANGSTER IN CENSORING ANYONE WH
DARED BRING IT UP RIGHT TWITTER
AND FACEBOOK SUSPENDED THE NEW
YORK POST FOR COVERING THE STORY
.
IF YOU WANTED COLLUSION IT WAS
DURING BACK AT YOU FROM YOUR i
PHONE.
MEANWHILE THEY COULD SPEW FROM
THEIR INTERNET ACCOUNT WITHOUT
INTERRUPTION.
AND NOW WHAT DO WE HAVE?
INSULATION, CRIME, PERHAPS EVEN
A WORLD WAR, DON'T BLAME ME, I
DIDN'T VOTE FOR BIDEN, BUT
NEARLY EVERYONE IN MY INDUSTRY
DID AND NOW WE'VE GOT A WAR ON
JOE'S WATCH EMMETT LIKE SO MANY
OTHER THINGS THAT REALLY REALLY
SUCK.
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUEST.
SHE HAS GOT MORE ENERGY THAN A
CHIPMUNK ON RED BULL,
"OUTNUMBERED" COHOST EMILY
COMPAGNO.
I WOULD LOVE TO BE HIS PRISONER
OF WAR, SUPREME COURT BOMB
TECHNICIAN AND FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR JONATHAN JERRY JOE.
AND SHE STARTS ST. PATRICK'S DA
IN A GREEN SWEATER AND ENDS IT
IN AN ORANGE JUMPSUIT, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF.
AND WHEN THIS MAN WEARS GREEN,
HE IS LOOKING FOR A RAIN FOREST
THE NWA WORLD TEMPLE VISION
CHAMPION TYRUS.
EMILY, EMILY, EMILY, EMILY, HOW
ARE YOU DOING?
>> I'M GOOD.
>> I WAS SAYING THAT BECAUSE I
WAS LOOKING FOR MY NOTES.
YOU REMEMBER, SHOULDN'T SOMEBOD
COMMISSIONED IN THE MEDIA BY
EVERYBODY AND ICE CREAM CAKE
THAT THEY DEMEANED OVER THE
STORY OR ANYTHING, IT IS CRAZY,
YOU WERE CALLED RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION IS FAIR TO GIVE
THE THING ABOUT THE MEDIA IS
THERE SO FLEETING.
THEY'RE OUR SEGMENTS, THEIR
BANDWIDTH IS LIKE ONE DAY.
AND THEY THEIR SUCCESS DEPENDS
ON GAS LIGHTING THE PUBLIC THAT
YOU FEEL THE SAME WAY, THAT YOU
DON'T REMEMBER THAT THEY
CANCELED THE NEW YORK POST FOR
THE SAME THING THEY SAID LAST
NIGHT PER THAT YOU WON'T
REMEMBER THE FACT THAT HAD BEEN
LAID OUT BY BEATABLE
ORGANIZATIONS.
THEY KEEP GAS LIGHTING
THEMSELVES IN THEIR INSULAR UNI
BECAUSE THEY KEEP REPORTING
WHATEVER THEY NEED, WHATEVER
THEY WANT YOU TO BELIEVE TO GET
THEIR APOLOGIST FOR THIS
ADMINISTRATION.
HUNTER IS STILL UNDER FEDERAL
INVESTIGATION FOR CRIMINAL
POTENTIALLY CRIMINAL TALKS
INVASION AS WELL AS LOBBING
THINGS AND MONEY LAUNDERING.
THINK ABOUT HOW MUCH PRESS
COVERAGE THE TRUMP FAMILY HAS
RECEIVED FOR THE INQUIRY INTO
THE PRESIDENTS TAX RECORDS.
EVERY DAY I SEE THAT MBC MSNBC
OR CNN HAS AT LEAST ONE ENTIRE
BLOCK DEDICATED TO THOSE TWO
THINGS THAT FRANKLY ARE BLATANT.
NOBODY IS COVERING EITHER OF
THEM.
YOU GUYS HAVE THEM TO AN OFFICE.
NOT THE WORST WHERE 60 PERCENT.
>> THERE IS FOUR OF THEM.
>> THAT IS A JOKE.
>> THIS GUY.
THIS GUY.
>> HAVE YOU EVER HEARD OF THE
BUTTERFLY EFFECT, LET ME EXPLAI
TO YOU A HYPOTHETICAL BUTTERFLY
EFFECT.
IF THE MEDIA HAD NOT QUASHED TH
LAPTOP, BIDEN WOULDN'T BE
PRESIDENT, TRUMP WOULD STILL BE
PRESIDENTS, AND PUTIN WOULDN'T
HAVE CALLED PULLED HIS IDIOCY
UNDER TRUMP BECAUSE PSYCHOPATHS
DON'T MESS WITH A GUY THAT IS
GOING TO OUT PSYCHOPATH THEM,
THAT IS THE BUTTERFLY EFFECT.
YOU AGREE, DISAGREE, FEEL FREE
TO CALL ME NAMES BECAUSE IT
TURNS ME ON.
>> GREGORY.
WHO IS JONATHAN.
BUT FOR REAL, RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION, THAT'S WHAT THI
WAS LABELED.
AND THE REAL BUTTERFLY EFFECT
HERE IS THAT RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION WENT FROM OAK,
THAT LAPTOP ISN'T REAL TO YAKIM
THAT WOMAN THAT WAS CARRIED OUT
OF A MATERNITY WORD, SHE WAS A
PAID ACTOR.
THAT'S WHAT REAL RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION IS.
WE JUST SPENT A YEAR ARGUING
OVER RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION
BECAUSE THE NEW YORK POST
COULDN'T KEEP THE TWITTER HANDL
UP RIGHT IF WE COULD REACH
EVERYBODY, HE WOULD BE RICHER
THAN NANCY PELOSI.
IF WE COULD REALLY REACH
EVERYBODY, BUT IT TAKES MORE
THAN JUST US.
FOR THE NEW YORK POST TO BE
SHAMED FOR THIS, AND BASICALLY
CALLED A SHAM INSTITUTION.
THAT IS A REAL SCANDAL.
I EXPECT MY POLITICIANS TO BE
CORRUPT, I REALLY DO, YOU
STARTED CORRUPT AND YOU MIGHT
WIN EARN YOUR WAY INTO GOOD
FAITH, BUT I EXPECT YOU TO BE
CORRUPT.
SO THE WHOLE HUNTER BIDEN LAPTO
STORY.
USING HIS IDIOT SON TO GET MONEY
, THAT DOESN'T SURPRISE ME
AND I REALLY DON'T EXPECT
CONSEQUENCES.
BUT WHEN YOU SHUT DOWN AND MEDI
SOURCES REPORTING ON IT, RIGHT
BEFORE THAT'S WHAT SENDS THE
ALARMS.
>> THAT IS LIKE PUTIN, BUT I
HAVE TO DISAGREE WITH MISTER
JONES, I DON'T BELIEVE THAT
HUNTER BIDEN IS AN IDIOT UNLESS
YOU MEAN IDIOT SAVANTS.
WE'VE DISCUSSED THIS OVER COFFEE
, SOMETIMES AT A CAFÉ.
I DON'T MIND THE AND DRUGS PART
I FIND THAT THE MEDIA BAND AS
STORY.
THE COMPROMISE OUR INSTITUTIONS
I CAN NEVER TRUST THEM AGAIN.
>> FOR ME IT WAS A WEIRD THING
TO BLOCK.
WE ALREADY KNEW HE DID DRUGS AN
HAD RELATIONS WITH EXPERTS, BUT
I THINK IT'S VERY STRANGE AND
IT'S NOT LIKE THEY WERE JUST
REALLY WORKING HARD ALL THIS
TIME TO AUTHENTICATE.
I REALLY FEEL LIKE THEY KNEW A
LITTLE EARLIER, BUT NOW YOU KNOW
, WE ARE A LITTLE BUSY
TALKING ABOUT SOME OTHER STUFF,
SO THEY WANT TO SAY OH, BY THE
WAY, IT'S REAL.
AGAIN, WHO CARES, WHY BOTHER TO
CALL IT RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION
ALTHOUGH, YAKIMA WHY BOTHER.
I WAS JUST THINKING MAYBE HE'S
UPSET BECAUSE HE DIDN'T LOOK
GOOD.
IF EVERYBODY THOUGHT HE LOOKED
GOOD, THEY WERE NAKED PICTURES,
YES, THAT IS ME.
>> TYRUS?
>> FIRST OF ALL, THAT COULD ONL
BE TRUE BECAUSE NO ONE TALKS
ABOUT WATERBED WATER SO THAT IS
FOR ONE.
>> WHERE DOES THE WATERBED WATE
GO?
>> I HAVE NEVER THOUGHT ABOUT I
YOU'VE NEVER EVEN BEEN ON ONE,
KAT, WATERBEDS DISAPPEARED IN
THE LATE 90s WHEN EVERYBODY
REALIZED THEY RUIN YOUR BACK EN
YOUR LIFE.
WHY CAN YOU NOT PUT FISH IN
THERE?
>> THERE IS NO OXYGEN.
>> TALK ABOUT REALLY KIND OF AN
ARTESIAN OR BOTTLED WATER I
COULD SELL FROM OLD WATERBEDS.
TO GET I WAS GROSSED OUT ENOUGH
AND I'M NOT FALLING FOR THAT.
SEE, I CAN LEARN.
BUT WE NEED TO STOP CALLING IT
PRUDENCE INTERFERENCE WE NEED T
STOP, IT IS AN AMERICAN ELECTIO
INTERFERENCE.
WE SAW IT IN THE PREVIOUS
CAMPAIGN, AND THEY MESSED UP
BECAUSE CLINTON'S CLINTON STUFF
WAS BROUGHT UP AND NOW COMEY
LOOKS LIKE HE DID THE RIGHT
THING BECAUSE